well blitek congratulations commissioner
first of all on the new job what does it
mean to you to be in charge now of the
London Fire Brigade just a feeling of it
immense pride you know I've been a
london firefighter for nearly 20 years I
love the job and in particular I love
this city the opportunity is given me
and to be able wear this uniform and
serve them protect the London public is
just I mean it's just a massive
privilege and to leave these fantastic
men and women at the brigade yeah I
couldn't be prouder but what a time to
take over at the start of a pandemic we
have obviously seen the ambulance
service right at the the forefront the
frontline the police trying desperately
to work out how to monitor the the
lockdown how is it impacted the fire
service I think ways demonstrate it is
as ever that we're a service that always
steps forward at a time when London
needs us I've got 300 firefighters
co-occuring ambulances with colleagues
from the London Ambulance Service I've
had over a hundred firefighters
providing services for those people who
lost their lives in their home so making
sure they're treated with dignity and
prepared for for burial or funeral
services I've had my logistics people
distributing their 10th million piece of
PPE on Friday so what what I think the
pandemic has done is allow us to step
into spaces that we perhaps wouldn't
normally occupy as well as delivering
our normal service to London and
Londoners you also took over quite soon
after a very critical
grenfell inquiry report phase one of the
inquiry what does that mean for the work
that you have to do for the for the fire
service what means is that we have to
bring forward the change required to
meet the recommendations laid down in
that report which we accept in full in
some of our systems in some of the
training we give them in some of the
leadership we provided them we let them
down and in letting them down we let
some of our communities down that night
and I'm very clear about that and
therefore I'm very focused on bringing
forward the change that's needed to
ensure that a tragedy like that never
happens in London again you were there
that night is it one of those events you
never really get over momentous
traumatic tragic for so many people for
me as tragic as it was it's been very
motivating you know
of family members who live on estates
just like that where the Tower of
Grenville was what it gave me was a
great sense of motivation to ensure that
it never happened again and to ensure
that you know the men and women of the
London Fire Brigade were never put in
that position again where they had to
respond to such a terrible tragedy what
was your personal experience personal
experience of it was that it was the
most serious incident I've ever attended
as a professional firefighter or officer
and I knew immediately on arrival
that my colleagues who were there and
who were risking their lives you know
time after time we were facing the
biggest professional firefighting
challenge of their lives and to be frank
what I saw in front of me was a
community torn apart a failure of the
building regulation system and and just
actually almost breathtaking the scale
of failure of the building and and how
we had so badly let so many people as a
society down in that community people
who should have gone to bed feeling
confident that they were safe where they
lived in modern London and yet had woken
up to a scene of utter carnage if you
had got there earlier do you think you
would have suggested that stay put was
revoked earlier I can only tell you what
my decision was in the moment and to me
in that moment it was very clear what
the appropriate decision was you know it
was no longer acceptable to advise
people that they were safe to stay put
and therefore it had to be changed
immediately so I think I can only answer
for my decision and I know that my
decision at that point in the night was
very very clear to me do you think about
those people who were left behind does
it weigh heavily on you what happened to
them yeah I think that scale of loss of
life in modern London and bearing in
mind that many of those people were
vulnerable themselves watching many of
the residents that's out law were
vulnerable people many of them were
people who had come to this country to
see refuge from war and other tragedy I
think they were badly let down by all
sorts of organisations and legislation
and years of erosion of good standards
and that actually we all have a great
responsibility to in
sure across government and all the
relevant agencies that nothing like this
could ever happen again so yes and
obviously one of the first things I did
as commissioner was to arrange to meet
the families of you know the victims
those most greatly affected by it and I
cannot tell you how both moving and
humbling that was in terms of their
courage and their their great desire to
seek the truth and see change so that
other people wouldn't have to suffer as
they did so I think as a professional
firefighter it would be odd if it didn't
weigh heavily on me do you recognize
that you have to rebuild trust with the
people of London you've are specifically
the 7,000 residents of high-rise blocks
to trust firefighters that sometimes
stay put is still the right advice for
them that's tough isn't it staple is
still the right advice in over 90% of
occasions so you know we're fairly clear
about that I completely accept though
that if you live in a high-rise block in
London he's very hard to trust that
advice knowing what happened at Grantham
we've seen in America what's happened
with George Floyd what happens if an
emergency services loses the trust of
the people it can be dangerous and very
difficult is that why it's so important
do you think to have a fire service a
fire brigade that is diverse that does
properly reflect the needs of its people
London is an incredible City I've grown
up here I've lived here all my life my
own family is mixed is very diverse and
I think that experience of growing up in
London being a lander has to be
reflected in my own service because
that's how you best understand
communities their needs and most
importantly you draw from the greatest
pool of talent the you know difference
brings such advantage to organisations
doesn't it in terms of thought and
ability to recognize risk and respond to
it so it's it's at a very heart of what
we do in London and we're working very
hard to ensure that London Fire Brigade
properly represents the communities we
serve in this you know incredible city
people have to still live in high
buildings don't they why should they
feel more safe today than they did two
years ago
because the transformation plan we bring
you through is very detailed or even in
the middle of
this pandemic it involves changes to
equipment so an increased fleet of
extended turntable adders which means we
can reach further upper high-rise
building and the introduction of smokers
which means that we can bring members of
the public safely down through
smoke-filled lobbies and actually since
their introduction have saved the lives
of 30 Londoners across I think
approximately 20 incidents they've
already proven their worth so real
changes are tangible or visible and that
the public will be able to understand is
keeping them safer and will it live with
you as a matter of regret that you
didn't get this done before that these
issues weren't in place earlier do you
think I think it's quite hard to know
what we didn't know at that point all I
do know is that we have learned the
lessons post Grenville and therefore we
will make all the changes we do need to
to ensure that we have the right
equipment the right training and the
right people in place to ensure our
response is fit for purpose in what is
now a different understanding of the
risk commissioner thank you thank you
very much